Speaker 1: All right. Thirdly, today this is also
big news. We have a horrible Supreme Court right
now that that shouldn't be news, but we do.
Thanks, by the way, to Donald Trump choosing
three people who are now on it rather than Hillary
Clinton. That cannot be ignored. That's a reality.
But that disastrous Supreme Court has put
a final stop to Donald Trump's demands
that White House records not be provided to the
committee investigating the Trump riots. This is
good news. CNBC reporting the Supreme Court has
rejected a Trump request to block the release
of records to the January 6th Committee. The
Supreme Court rejected a request from former
President Trump to block those records.
The ruling, which Trump cannot appeal,
sets the stage for more than 700
pages of Trump White House records
to soon be sent by the National Archives to
the committee. That's an important detail.
It is not now Trump who has to release them. It
is the National Archives that will release them.
Trump had argued that he had the authority as a
former president to invoke executive privilege to
prevent the disclosure of the records. President
Biden has declined to invoke executive privilege
for the records which the committee wants as part
of its probe of the invasion of the Capitol by a
mob of Trump supporters. This is a very, very good
decision and it is the correct decision. Notably,
the Supreme Court order, the Supreme
Court decision was eight to one. The
one was Justice Clarence Thomas, who dissented
and said now Trump should be able to block it.
And what is particularly disturbing about
that is that Clarence Thomas wife cheered
the Stop the Steal rally on January 6th. That
ultimately was one of the primary inciting factors
of those Trump riots, and she subsequently
apologized to her husband's law clerks.
But given Clarence Thomas obvious conflict of
interest here, if he had respect for the law,
he would recuse himself from anything even
remotely related to the Jan. six Trump riots. But
it is Clarence Thomas, after all. And imagine, I
mean, just think about that the wife of a Supreme
Court justice was cheering, cheering, cheering the
event and the individuals that led to an attempted
insurrection at the country. In the country
where your husband is a Supreme Court justice,
it's absolutely stunning stuff. But Ginni Thomas
is maybe something to focus on on a different day.
That's the Supreme Court decision. This appears
to be the end. I know we say that all the time
with Trump and trying to hide records. Well, this
this is it now and then something else happens.
By every reasonable stretch of the imagination,
this is a Supreme Court decision, and this is it.
And the records will be provided to the committee,
whether they will be made public deliberately or
because they will leak or whatever we do not
yet know. But that's the Supreme Court decision,
and it is the correct decision. Let me know what
you think. Will we ever see those records? You can
find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We're going
to take a very quick break and be right back.